come on
come on game
he kept so bad that was mind-blowing
conor's saying he cannot believe it this
is i
guys we what this could be a crazy upset
so
i'm shocked that giga eventually won the
game not because
he didn't play better but i felt like he
was missing all of his opportunities
and then finally when it when it was
when push came to shove he he finally
delivered
delivered on the most important one
which is a checkmate one movement
so that's history gig has never beaten
conor until now
conor the heavy favorite to win
tournament arc is now down one nothing
it's win or go home for sea dog
wow at this point the rating difference
really means nothing
these two players can beat each other
and and so
game two sea dog has the white pieces
and
he must win he cannot just draw
he has to beat gigguk right now to stay
in the in the running for for the
championship
and you know what's very interesting is
that they've played many times and
it's just like casual games like if you
play blitz and you know it's not in a
tournament setting it kind of just
doesn't really hold as much weight but
when you're in a tournament setting
that win matters that much more and
you're concentrating and you're thinking
even harder
so i think that's what happened here and
maybe conor was a little bit lacks and
said
well i mean i beat him so many times
yeah i wonder if conor's gonna give
up exactly what he was feeling if we
listen in right now
in these opening moves
let's go push this
i can't believe that i can't believe it
conor's still reeling from that first
loss
and look at gigguk he's playing this
sort of suffocating chest that we've
seen him practice
that 1.5 player chess
okay
this is the most intense and quiet we've
seen conor
i think he's feeling the pressure
wow wow this is this is so
intense this
is this is rough you know this is uh
it's very interesting to see um
when a person who was the favorite now
loses a game and now
they are in a must-win situation
yeah and i wonder if uh the hangover of
like finally losing to someone who i
think that sea dog has known that google
is getting better and better and better
i mean conor has been
the favorite here in a lot of people's
eyes for good reason but
has been improving and i think now you
know does he find himself
right really really uh bring out bring
out the best
the best in his chest which he i i
thought he was on
pace to do it last game before this g5
movement i think you said it jt
maybe he just got a little overconfident
got a little relaxed
because it was just such a horrible
horrible blunder but
um but now now we'll see white should be
better here
if he finds the right moves i mean he
should find a way to maybe trade the
knights
on d4 okay and then bring the queen out
i thought maybe to the jack of seven
this is this is risky opening the door
for black to get a lot of counter play
here
um and indeed look at giga he plays rook
b8 very quickly
yeah he may have been thinking well
let's destroy the pawns on the other
side making the prospect of castling
pretty ugly in either direction but
the yikes that's a good point that's a
good point art
um that could have been what what connor
is thinking as far as getting rid of the
pawn here because the black king doesn't
have safety on this side of the board
long term now that giga has already
advanced the pawns
so that that's a really that's a really
good point i think that even if the
computers objectively think black is
okay here
it is interesting as long as conor gets
castled
and his king is safe from a practical
point of view black is going to have a
lot to figure out
about where this king is safe in the
long term
and jt i know you've talked to gigguk
about you know things like
king safety and stuff like that do you
think he's gonna
he's gonna look at this situation and
just make a decision to go on an all-out
attack or
i think he will actually i think he's
gonna go
all out he's winning you know that's the
psyche like okay like now that i'm
winning i really have to take this
opportunity
and try to like punish him
well let's listen in because we see a
lot of talk coming out of that camera
and
he must be sharing his plans so let's
listen to them
considering the trade
what's he gonna do
if i check him
goes for a check and you should notice
here that sea dog is playing extremely
quickly
after 14 moves only down 45 seconds
yeah he's got to be thinking on his
opponent's turn which is important
how can i how can i how can i keep
applying this pressure
okay he says he wants to continue to
apply pressure he's trapped my rook
that was very good advantage from him to
notice that
and and how amazing would it be
if we had two games that ended up in the
two matches that ended up in the blitz
tie break on the final stream
on the season finale you can't ask for
anything better than that but uh
maybe we maybe we don't even get there
because there have to be
tactics uh lying in wait here on this
side of the board right
just weave in the twitch chat said he
thought bishop e3 was very impressive by
conor to find the retreating defensive
move i agree
we know gig is on the attack uh jt
what kind of attacking moves do you
think we might see
i mean i think this is going to be
really hard for him to find
but now that you are basically
dominating
on the queen side you should start
thinking about other parts of the board
and well there are two two options right
there's one
keep attacking on the queen side but i
think that option is just limiting your
options
and i think you should start attacking
on the king side now that you have now
that all of the pieces kind of shifted
over to the queen side
for defense because the biggest problem
though for black is that the rook is
potentially trapped
so queen of six is played
he's bringing out pieces like you said
but a lot of conor's problems are solved
if he just gets the king
out of the center if he gets castle here
and and everything opens up the knight
is no longer pinned
so you have threats of knight c4 the
rook is suddenly a big
problem this is this could be a really
dangerous lesson for giga could be if
depending
very good for conor he finally castles
because here's the thing like even from
a practical point of view
now gig has to find all the best moves
to hold on with a rook that has
wandered so far from home right
i mean there's already a threat and i
see boris that's right on the board
and right um this is this is going to be
a really big moment for giggup
uh-oh and that's that's the kind of what
happens in a position like this without
the best move from here on out
all of a sudden your rook has just has
gone i mean queen c1 and knight c4
okay lol not queen c1 wow danny
but the idea of the rookie job like okay
connor connor
doesn't play as bad as me big surprise
and finds knight c4 but you get what i'm
saying the rook has gone too far
but honestly if that night on d4 and now
they have a lot of dark square
weaknesses right so that bishop is going
to be great
and in comparison to the white star
square bishop is really bad
yeah that's totally true i mean but
again it's going to come down to the
material i think that
i think that now that the rook is
trapped uh
oh oh oh oh oh yeah i think conor's
sending us to our second tie break of
the day wow
did we not get the finale we wanted to
mount people come on
and i told you this is going to be the
highest episode
of the tournament art i told you guys
yesterday
i told you guys in my twitter post i
told you guys
oh i'm so excited this is this is okay i
mean okay
gig is gonna be all in now with an
attack and like you said he was feeling
aggressive he's winning in the match all
that stuff and i
i think i don't think it was the wrong
psychology but
every player in their growth learns
lessons of things like a rook takes b2
where you learned that it was a good
idea but maybe you missed
the potential consequence and bishop b3
by chess weave pointed out grandmaster
uh boros in the twitch chat he's totally
right this was a heads up play
it doesn't matter that black maybe with
perfect play was still okay but that
trapped the rook
and that that's going to ultimately be
why conor won the game was that bishop
e3 move
well i would like to see what conor is
thinking right he has i'm
super excited i'm wondering if he's
breathing a sigh of relief
um
it was definitely a sigh yeah
you can't do anything immediately hmm
he knows his king is safe right
i can't really do anything with the
pawns either
but on a second look the king side does
seem a bit shaky for white yeah i mean
maybe with a good sacrifice giga can get
in and we have the first
muda of the day
i knew it was an anime reference that's
like oh yeah it's a super anime
reference yeah
i laugh because i don't know things i do
that as a dad a lot i think swinging my
knight back around was a good if you say
that
but as fast as you can you want to open
up this chest switch chat would love you
like it's going to be important
uh we can we can save that so sad that i
lost that first game it was such a dumb
game i shouldn't have lost i don't like
making it
attention i see okay fair enough
connor's still thinking about that first
game he mentioned that
uh that was a sour experience for him
just now
and he's probably not feeling too
comfortable there's a fork now obviously
but there's no way he can get it
no way no way
wow all these pieces are eyeing the
king's side i i i just
i need to know how black gets through
well but connor seems to feel
i mean obviously giggit was the one on
the clock there and trying to come up
with something and i think connor had
calculated he wanted to play this f3
move
which is a little risky but overall it's
it's hard to lose this if he makes a
trade or i think what conor's plan is i
think he likes the idea of bringing this
bishop here to trade off
this sort of meddling meddling bishop on
c5 which is a nice plan
to try to bring the bishop here to trade
off the attacker and indeed he does it
that's what i predicted when he played
f3 that his
it wasn't necessary he could have traded
the bishop for the night other things
but i think he spied this bishop as his
problem
which is a good it's a good uh
it's a good sign of technique meaning
when you're better
you just recognize what are the biggest
pain points let's eliminate them one
pain point at a time because again
that's just
the chest uh psychology should always be
if you're winning you should always win
and you do that by being disciplined and
by just eliminating your problems
so i like the idea of bishop f2 even if
it wasn't totally necessary it shows
that he saw this this problem
so and and what about uh h3 instead of
trading the bishops first
i think i think either way um gigging
knows he's all in right now
he's he's pushing harry up the board
right if conor makes a horrible mistake
like to make a trade on the h-file
something that
brings life to the black pieces he could
get in trouble
i think if he finds the move g3 this
game will be over
um but if he oh
that's like i said if he finds g3
h g2 check
we have to listen in on gitguick right
now and see if he sees
yeah that's the fork right and he can't
take free rook
it's fine by me oh
what a turn of fence and now we're back
even now we're back even
let's go
now danny he just said something very
interesting that cues you into the
psychology said now we're back
even does he not realize he's doing so
much better than that
he's focused on the material part of it
because he because remember
this the biggest pain point in giga's
brain is that he lost his rook on b2
back on move 17 right so his whole
psychology is okay now we're even i've
got my rook back
and i think that's already okay
but i i do think it continues to show
gig sort of psychological perspective is
that
he's just trying to stay with conor i
think gingka has had a healthy
underdog mindset coming into this match
that has kept him super focused
because um and yes it led to missed
opportunities in that first game that i
highlighted
but ultimately it's proving to pay off
because
one of the best things you can do as a
chess player is to just never rest on
your laurels it's okay if you're winning
to think you're close to even
because as long as you're objectively
find the best move it doesn't matter
right you don't need to have the
emotional
comfort of thinking you're winning or
losing like just find the best move and
i think that
i think gig's mindset is actually really
clear i think conor is just
clearly off his game right now he's just
not considering gigger's threats
which is why he missed this h shakes g2
check
i'm just blown away right now i'm sorry
this is just crazy to me i just really
thought conor was
really a heavy favorite and and he is
he's not in his best chess and if queen
takes f3 his played here omg's are snaps
get your emotes out yeah he's feeling it
let's listen in
wow connor is feeling the heat
you know i would say he's not letting it
show but
his silence kind of says the whole story
this is the muta muda muda check after
check after check after check
no mistake oh yeah what's a buddha
buddha buddha
he said it we'll educate we'll educate
you later dude
yeah we'll sit you down
we'll teach you the ways yeah we'll have
a anime one-on-one
uh lesson for you we'll show you the
hormone the hammer
[Laughter]
under the greatness ah okay
and great moves being played like a
blind right
no it's not [__] my god
connor is definitely feeling the heat
yeah you see he's desperate to
desperate for her to make a mistake and
he's not making one
if you're this is tough
yeah he's bad that's a bad sign right
there the last thing we saw with connor
uh before we switched away the fact that
he was arrowing through the
moves yes i was just about to it means
he's living in the past
and he's frustrated with the mistakes
that he's made this is uh
i've had so many lessons on this both in
terms of training that i was given by
grandmasters and by
you know training with my students that
he's just
he's just not like the fact that he was
better earlier but still beating himself
up about the game before remember right
before he blundered
he's just not he's just not present
right now and that's a normal thing that
happens when you've like
decided i'm better i should win and so
you just keep thinking that if it's not
going your way
that the story is you've done something
wrong you just you have to remain
present and he's
you can't be second-guessing moves
mid-game do that after the game
but i will say that one thing i'll give
conor credit for if he comes back if he
finds queen e2 here oh he does okay
i'm gonna make a bold prediction conor
wins this game because the one thing he
did
was even when things went off went off
the rails and when things were not
what he wanted them to be he kept the
tempo and he's going to win this game
because of time
i really think so that's going to pay
off i like your prediction actually
danny
yeah giggling's only got a minute left
on the clock let's listen in because
he's work
he's got to go fast no
yeah because he can't move his queen in
the way
we talk about this all the time getting
the initiative you have to be able to
keep it
under a minute wow this is tough um [__]
now this is that what now moment right
your attack seems to have finished
do i want to castle now oh i'm running
out of time
[__]
i want to get my queen i want to get my
queen out there
i'm gonna be living on increments soon
that's that's bad
okay so lisey understands the concept of
being able to gain some time
by moving quickly yeah the increment
concept
but i i still think it's going to be too
little too late
i've i've i've not got enough time to
think about this i'm just going to offer
up the queen trade
he can take it if he wants it puts me in
a good position because then i got my
rook up here
connor issuing the check first
earns more time on google's clock
yeah [__] it and conor five minutes on
the clock
i've got to win this through increment
now okay got it gotta
gotta start gotta start planning this
out quick
okay
the goal is to move fast
the checks will keep coming making a
difference
yes yes
oh my goodness oh man
look i can't say anything this is crazy
there's just
neither of them see it
he's just living on increment
my pawns are trapped in the corner oh
this game's lost
this game's [__] lost wow we are
going to go to tie break
there's nothing i can do
i don't know yet i mean connor hasn't
put it away
there's nothing i can do i've lost
i've lost gigguk is already basically
a really beautiful move here hopefully
we are able to see it
he's he's emotionally divested from this
game
yeah but he shouldn't be it's too bad
because
neither player realizes that rook on h4
is for free
that's a free run it's almost like c
doug thinks he
only also has 13 seconds on his glock
yeah and c
dog did the right thing earlier which is
why i predicted he would come back and
win because he kept the pressure and got
gig under this horrible time
now he's finally slowing down now if he
takes a second
and just gets back to playing the best
move on the board he's going to win the
game
because at this point white isn't even
objectively losing even if the rook
saves itself like white is not worse
here so
by the way the book did save itself um
as long as as long as conor plays good
moves here he'll actually be
fine
this is a really tense game wow yeah
dude
this is no i and i think david might
realize now
it's funny he was emotionally kind of
like not through in the towel but he
just figured it was a matter of time
before he lost no time
now i think he i think he uh
i think maybe he he realizes he still
has a rook uh-oh
maybe for not for long will conor see
the fork
there is a killer can we see
can we see what carter's thinking right
now yes let's see if he spots it
he can guarantee almost
the tie break
putting a lot of pressure on himself as
well he is but he's not moving too
quickly he sees that he's got three and
a half minutes on the clock
could hear a pin drop all the way in
tokyo
oh and he cannot repeat if he repeats he
loses
oh boy
remember the stakes everyone a draw wins
the tournament for gig
if you repeat with the knight to c5 it's
a draw
oh
i don't know if he knows three move
repetition if black plays king c7 it's a
draw oh
no don't play king c7 please oh
by repetition what
can we see but wow
connor it's feeling oh my god
what how is that a drool by repetition
[Music]
oh my god look who came in this room is
that
oh my god oh my god
[Music]
oh my god oh my god oh my god
what's chad saying what is chat saying
this was the most anime
this was the most anime final